for old dudes in Vegas just innately and
naturally you're gonna find a bit of
enjoyment in a movie like this how can
you not hang over the hill which they
call Last Vegas so in Last Vegas Michael
Douglas's character is Michael Douglas's
age he's marrying a 32 year old woman
god bless that man so he and his friends
played by Morgan Freeman Robert DeNiro
and Kevin Kline all go to Las Vegas for
his bachelor party and they're now a
bunch of old dudes livin it up which is
fun to watch and the cast completely
makes this movie the movie without the
cast they had in this movie they just
had like four random old guys in this
movie you'd have a very generic and
basic movie but with the cast they have
they have a pretty generic and basic
movie with a really good cast I liked
all these guys in this movie you can
tell they were just having fun they're
like I want to make a movie were a bunch
of old dudes like us still have fun in
life which is a really good theme in the
movie it's like people roll over and
they play dead when they're older they
shouldn't it's a better way to learn
that lesson then in Vegas not gonna lie
as much as I love these dudes in this
movie the movie is a bit choppy at times
it messy its classic and you've heard me
about this in movies before now
you have a scene that exists for no
other reason other than this one
punchline the scenes about 30 seconds
long and you skip over to another scene
you're just left with that feeling of
white that scene is just for that one
punch line really stop it and it's a bit
unbelievable - I mean Kevin Klein's
gonna land this hot 20-something year
old chick and I'm Michael Douglas no he
can land at the hot 32 year old chick
for sure he did he has he landed
Catherine zeta-jones but she was younger
than she is now and he was still the
mummy but kevin kline i just i don't see
that although kevin kline was my
favorite character in this movie he had
the best lines his dialogue was really
well-written or at least well delivered
a lot of these guys though I don't think
they know they're being filmed Robert
DeNiro plays Robert De Niro Morgan
Freeman plays Morgan Freeman Michael
Douglas will dwell manizer playboy dude
Michael Douglas does play Michael
Douglas is like a Salinas there's
nothing about this movie that's gonna
jump out at you and be like ah this is
the movie to see because these
performances kick ass so everyone in
this movie is an old dude playing
themselves in a movie made
how old dudes can still have fun in
Vegas in the end Last Vegas was a filler
movie it's like that movie that comes
out to reserve auditorium 8 in your
local movie theater for Thor the dark
world for when that comes out I did
enjoy elements of this movie but in the
end I walked out of the movie going
alright well the movie exists this is a
good movie for your midlife crisis but
I'm just not there yet so in the end
hangover the hill is a pretty good time
among your second midlife crisis if
you're drunk yeah your party
hey forego it I was gonna say cuz it
dawns on you that the movie is a comedy
and you don't really laugh at all you
just you enjoy seeing these old dudes
have a good time but I would enjoy
seeing any old dude have a good time in
Vegas right so for you guys what's your
favorite old person in any movies old is
a general term I get that but you know
pick your old badass whoever they are
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you